Speaker 1: you know, the biggest beneficiary
of the last 24 hours, 48 hours, 72 hours of
coverage of the Derek Chauvin case and other
things.
The biggest beneficiary has been Matt Gates,
who has been able to get a respite from the
focus on him, but he is still in full damage
control mode.
We're going to talk about that after the break.
And we are also hearing about a Republican
that supposedly is moving in the direction
of running for president in twenty, twenty
four.
I will tell you who it is and the implications
right after this short break.
As I mentioned before the break, one of the
biggest beneficiaries of the last 48 to 72
hours of the news cycle being on the Derek
Chauvin case has been Republican Congressman
Matt Gates, who is in full, full damage control
mode.
He should be in resignation mode, not damage
control mode.
And I believe that the attention is going
to get back to Matt Gates.
There's a very interesting Daily Beast article
which points out that quotes his latest campaign
finance report, reflects a public relations
scramble that began even before he acknowledged
being the focus of a federal investigation.
We now are learning that Matt Gates knew much
earlier that he was the focus of this investigation
and that he was already working on his public
relations campaign.
The filing, which covers the three months
between January and March, writes The Daily
Beast, shows that Gates has incurred unprecedented
fundraising expenses during a typically quiet
period.
In that time, Gates dropped six figures on
a direct mail blitz, shelling out more for
fundraising services than he did in all of
2012.
We now understand the cycle.
One of my criticisms of the status quo of
the House of Representatives and two year
terms is that with two year terms, you basically
get elected, you get six months and then you
start campaigning again.
Matt Gates is doing the fundraising during
that six month period where you are typically
not campaigning.
It's basically a year and a half of campaigning,
not to.
Matt Gates is starting right away, and it
tells us quite a bit about the panic that
he is likely feeling as a result of these
investigations.
The article goes on to say, Gates also paid
five thousand dollars in strategic consulting
fees to notorious political operative Roger
Stone, and he gave money to a number of Republican
Florida state lawmakers that he has never
supported before.
Would it appears he's trying to do there.
And again, we're left to read into the actions
of a madman.
It seems he's trying to curry favor with some
of these fellow Florida Republicans so that
they will not abandon him and hopefully will
speak out in his support if and when it gets
really, really ugly for him, which could be
any time.
The Daily Beast writes that the report also
indicates Gates may be increasingly isolated.
He's received no contributions from his Republican
colleagues.
More than anything, the filing reflects a
concerted effort to bolster support ahead
of the creeping shadow of the investigation.
Gates has spent roughly one hundred and seventy
K on direct mail this year.
One hundred and sixty thousand of it all on
one day, March 31st.
I think that's the day after I know I was
on or I was on our break that day.
That must be the day after the bizarre interview
with Tucker Carlson.
The previous day, The New York Times broke
the news that the Justice Department was looking
into whether he had sex with a 17 year old
and paid for her travel, which possibly violates
federal sex trafficking laws.
Gates has also invested in fundraising, paying
Nevada based Redrock Strategies nearly one
hundred and sixty K for fundraising consulting.
That's more than he spent on fundraising services
in 2019 and 2020 combined.
That is stunning.
Last week, Politico reported Gates spent six
figures on TV ads punching back against the
accusations, 30 second spot slated to run
in his home district in the Florida Panhandle
and on national cable networks, asking supporters
to, quote, fight back against a, quote, multi
week fake news cycle targeting CNN.
There is one expense in particular, raising
eyebrows, a five thousand dollar strategic
political consulting fee to Drake Ventures.
That's the company belonging to Roger Stone.
Friday, the Department of Justice sued Stone
and his wife, saying they owed millions of
dollars in unpaid taxes and are using that
very same Drak ventures to shelter more than
one million dollars.
Isn't that unbelievable?
Look at look at how the tentacles of gates
are spreading into so many different things.
So there's the investigation into Gates, which
we already talked about.
And then now in light of that, it's sort of
weird that Gates was the lone no vote on some
sex trafficking bill a couple of years ago
or whatever.
Okay, that's weird.
And we're starting to see that in a new light.
Then we learn about Gates's alleged involvement
in a shill candidate scheme in a different
district in the state of Florida.
We had a report on that, I believe it was
earlier mid last week.
Now we find out that Gates paid a consulting
fee to Roger Stone's company.
And it is the very same company that now allegedly
is a way for Roger Stone and his wife to shelter
more than a million dollars and avoid paying.
Taxes.
It's so tied in with all of this stuff and
in a sense, I don't feel bad for him, but
Gates may end up being another sort of victim
of the Trump grift.
The way that the Trump grift works is Trump
loves you, loves you, loves you for as long
as you are saying good things about him and
for as long as you are useful to him and Trump
will introduce you to all sorts of different
people.
Who knows how Matt Gates ended up sort of
entangled with Roger Stone in the first place?
My instinct is that it has something to do
with Donald Trump.
As soon as you are no longer useful to Trump
or as soon as you are potentially a problem
due to your own issues that you were having
from a public relations standpoint, Trump
is gone.
And indeed, the reports are that Matt Gates
has been trying to meet with Trump.
Matt Gates has been claiming that he has Donald
Trump support, although it's not completely
clear that that's the case.
And it is another in at least partially.
I'm not saying Gates did the stuff.
If Gates did the stuff he's accused of doing,
he didn't do it because of Donald Trump.
But he is another one of these guys who got
sort of lulled into Trump's circle as a brownnosing
sycophant and then dropped like a bad habit
as soon as he was no longer useful.
One other piece of this very extensive Daily
Beast article about what's going on with Matt
Gates quote, The report also suggests Gates
has few friends in Washington.
While Gates swore off donations from corporate
PACs, he kept the door open to donations from
candidate committees.
But he has so far reported no financial support
in twenty twenty one from friends in Congress
like Jim Jordan and Steve Scalise, both of
whom donated back in 2020.
While Gates made the same day four thousand
dollar donations to Mike Lee and Rand Paul.
Gates did not give money to any House colleagues.
He did send out a thousand, a few five one
thousand dollar donations to five Republican
Florida senators and had not donated to their
campaigns previously.
So I would expect that the media attention
will go back to Matt Gates at some point relatively
soon, at some point relatively soon.
I would imagine we will know whether there
will be charges filed as a result of what
appear to be multiple investigations into
Matt Gates.
But certainly Gates must be thrilled that
for the last two to three days, the focus
has been not on him, but rather on Derek.
Shervin, we'll get back to him, no question
about it.